summers in miami can be hot
i'm told the humidity makes it feel
hotter why is this
excellent question lebron let's first
think about what people are talking
about when they even say humidity and
there's a couple of ways to think about
humidity but typically when you hear the
weatherman or in everyday talk people
say hey it's really humid out there it's
really high humidity they're talking
about relative they're talking about
relative humidity and it's usually
indicated by a percentage and let's just
think about what the different
percentages of relative humidity mean so
right over here we'd have zero percent
let me mark it like this
so here we'd have zero percent relative
humidity and over at the extreme other
end you have 100 percent relative
humidity at any given point the air is
someplace between zero percent humidity
and 100
relative humidity at zero percent
relative humidity it's essentially
saying that there's no water vapor in
the air or very or a non-measurable
amount of water vapor in the air and so
if we go to this molecular view of what
might look like a little water droplet
maybe on the surface of our skin so just
to be clear these are skin molecules not
even skin cells these are the actual
skin molecules i just simplified them as
as brown circles
and this right over here this is the
actual what this is these are actual
water molecules so these are water
water molecules and maybe it's a drop of
sweat or a little water that got dropped
on our skin and it's in its it's in its
liquid state and in a liquid state you
have these hydrogen bonds between the
molecules that aren't super strong so it
allows these molecules to slide past
each other and that's why liquid flows
the way it does and we've already talked
about why sweat makes you cooler but
we'll review it a little bit whenever we
talk about the temperature of something
we're actually talking about the average
kinetic energy or the average motional
energy of the molecules that make up
that thing but it's the average on an
individual molecular basis they could
have very different kinetic energies
this molecule right here might be going
really fast in that direction this
molecule might be going slower in that
direction this molecule might be going
super fast in that direction this
molecule going in this direction when we
talk about the temperature of this water
we're just talking about the average
kinetic energy some of this this
molecule might be rotating really fast
that way this one might be rotating that
way this one might be vibrating with a
certain kinetic energy
and so sweating what it does for us is
if i let's say my skin molecules they
have some temperature associated with it
so these are all these are all vibrating
and bumping into each other a certain
degree and then they will vibrate and
add kinetic energy they'll bump into
these water molecules and these water
molecules will bump into each other and
what happens with the water molecules is
the ones that have a really high kinetic
energy have a higher chance of escaping
the bonds with the other water molecules
so for example maybe this one has a
really high kinetic energy and it's in
the exact right direction and so it's
going to go really fast in that
direction and it's enough it has enough
kinetic energy to essentially escape the
this attraction with the other water
molecules and so it enters a gaseous
state it essentially becomes it
essentially becomes water vapor it just
gets mixed with the rest of the air and
so when you have zero percent humidity
you have no water vapor up here it's
very easy for something to do this it's
very easy for it to escape maybe this
one maybe this one too is about to
escape in that direction and as we
already talked about when you have your
things with the highest kinetic energy
leaving a system then your average
temperature for the system is going to
go down you're losing the things that i
guess you could say are the hottest that
have the highest kinetic energy so at
this state right over here evaporation
is very easy
easy
easy evaporation or you can even say
easy evaporative cooling so at zero
percent humidity you can sweat very
efficiently it really cools you down
evaporation
easy evaporation at zero percent
but as you have more and more water
vapor here we go up this humidity scale
so let's say we start having a little
bit more water vapor in the air so
that's some water vapor
in the air as you have more and more
water vapor in the air
you still have molecules that can leave
but now you have some probability that
some molecules in the air might actually
condense and become part of the water
again so you still might have some net
evaporation but it's not going to be as
much because you could have some water
vapor that gets captured by these water
molecules and so the rate of evaporation
is going to slow down all the way that
you get to 100 percent
percent relative humidity at a hundred
percent relative humidity and it depends
the the actual amount of water vapor
depends on the temperature and on the
the pressures we're dealing with but at
100 relative humidity you have so much
water vapor you have so much water vapor
that it is possible still it is still
possible that some of your liquid water
might have enough kinetic energy to
escape but you're just as likely to have
water vapor condense you have so much in
the atmosphere
that for as much as this is evaporating
you have other water vapor that is
condensing you have water vapor that
starts to be that starts to get i guess
you could say captured by your water
drop
it gets captured by your water drop so
at this point at 100 percent you have no
net evaporation
the air is saturated
no
no net
evaporation so at that point at that
point having sweat is useless you're not
having no net evaporation you're not
able to take away your high energy
particles and so the cooling down that
you normally do for sweating is no
longer in effect and we see that here in
this chart from the national weather
service they give the heat index if you
have if the real temperature is let's
say the real temperature is 90 degrees
90 degrees we see as we have higher and
higher relative humidities they're
starting at 40 relative humidity because
that's just when you just begin to start
to notice it all the way to 100
the effective temperature what it feels
like it goes all the way to 132 degrees
or it feels like 132 degrees
and this is important because the body
isn't cooling it it's not just a
perception thing it also can affect your
health because the body can't cool
itself down anymore it can't dissipate
itself through it can't dissipate heat
through the traditional process of
evaporative cooling